trois défis
communisme communisante
vérité
d'hommes semblables niveau
alors bonjour à toutes et à tous vous
écoutez scopeo l'observatoire politique
je suis l e10 membres de scopeo je vous
souhaite la bienvenue sur notre chaîne
pour l'entrevue politique numéro 14
aujourd'hui nous sommes très heureux de
poursuivre notre série d'entrevues
politique avec monsieur david caïla
économistes la lumière c'était danger et
membre du collectif des économistes
atterrés par le passé vous avez écrit
deux ouvrages à propos de l'union
européenne avec coralie delaume qui nous
a quitté il ya un an et avec qui vous
rendez hommage en fondant l'association
les amis de coralie delaume ce sont deux
ouvrages que l'on vous recommande
vivement qu'ils sont très éclairant sur
cette grande machine qu'est l'union
européenne au programme d'aujourd'hui le
dernier ouvrage de notre invité intitulé
populisme et néolibéralisme est urgent
de tout repenser je laisse maintenant la
parole à dimiti membres de scopeo pour
qu'elle pose plus précisément le décor
de ce podcast
merci elodie bonjour à celles et ceux
qui nous écoutent et surtout bonjour à
vous monsieur david cayer là bonjour
vous nous fait le plaisir aujourd'hui de
nous accorder cette entrevue pour
discuter ensemble du néolibéralisme en
effet en octobre 2020 apparaît votre
dernier mot mais avant de démarrer entre
vieux monsieur caillé là je vous laisse
vous présenter brièvement pour ceux qui
nous écoutent et bien je suis économiste
enseignant chercheur à l'université
d'angers
mon travail en tant qu'économiste c'est
d'analyser
les dynamiques de des sociétés à travers
le prisme de l'économie c'est-à-dire la
question de la richesse sa création sa
répartition
et donc dans ce cadre là il a mangé
publie des articles de recherche
participent à des conférences mais
également je lis les livres plus grand
public qui sont là aussi pour un peu
vulgariser les connaissances et
également apporté une contribution au
débat politique donc mon dernier ouvrage
beaucoup des semaines et au libéralisme
comme ouvrage qui est paru en français
et en anglais aussi
donc en france et chez le bo xi période
non mais c'est zéro keynes et l'argument
de ce livre c'est de montrer comment le
néo libéral ou
mais plutôt la forme de gestion de
l'état a fini par
développer des formes de contestations
politiques que l'on peut appeler le
populisme
voilà en gros
très bien merci beaucoup d'abord pour
tous nos auditeurs comprennent bien les
différents termes qu'on entend beaucoup
dans le débat public y sont libéralisme
ultra libéralisme ou bien néolibéralisme
et aussi dans le cadre européen on
entend beaucoup parler d'eux hors d'eau
libéralisme est-ce que vous pouvez nous
donner une idée ni d'une définition
voire nous expliquer distinguer ces
différents concepts pour qu'on comprenne
bien et qu'on compare tous du même du
même du même étage déjà ce qu'il faut
dire c'est que le terme néolibéralisme
est souvent un terme qui est employé par
des opposants au néolibéralisme des eaux
aux opposants à la politique actuelle
puisque c'est un terme péjoratif 1 et
très peu de deux chercheurs de
responsables politiques par exemple 10
s'affirmer aux libéraux du coup on sait
plus trop ce qu'il ya derrière ce terme
est en réalité il ya toute une histoire
en fait le néolibéralisme c'est ce que
j'essaie de démontrer dans mon livre
pourquoi on dit néolibéralisme parce que
il y a derrière
une vision libérale mais qui n'est pas
celle du libéralisme classique celui du
19ème siècle ou celui de smith donc en
fait le libéralisme en fait il ya de
multiples formes alors au coeur de la
pensée libérale il ya la reconnaissance
de l'individu comme un être autonome
responsable et sa s'oppose au
libéralisme s'oppose aux sociétés dites
aux listes dans lesquelles l'individu
n'est qu'un élément d'un tout et il est
soumis on va dire aux institutions
sociales est ce que veut faire le
libéralisme c'est en quelque sorte
émancipé l'individu vis-à-vis de ces
exceptions donc au départ le libéralisme
c'est une fille le dossier des lumières
c'est une pensée une doctrine
doctrine uns pour les autres et
tellement c'est une manière de concevoir
la société dexia 2 comme il y en
organiser
cette société donc c'est quelque chose
que lors du politique c'est pas tout à
fait la même chose une crémerie il
théorise une représentation du monde ils
ont créé une manière de deux commandants
de considérer ce que doit être une bonne
politique et donc les libéraux à
l'origine ce sont des intellectuels qui
cherchent à concevoir une société qui
reconnaît l'individu et qui cherche à
développer l'émancipation des individus
et donc c'est une philosophie un très
large derrière ce libéralisme en fait il
va y avoir plein plein de doctrine un
peu différent qui a notamment des
libéraux qui vont être anti institutions
sociales qui vont considérer que plus on
comment dire on
en fait ils vont chercher à
éviter l'oppression de l'ag du
l'individu par les institutions sociales
et donc
verser un peu à démanteler l'état ou à
démanteler tous les pouvoirs de l'état
de manière à ce que l'individu soit
davantage libre et alors derrière cela
il ya l'idée par exemple
retrouve chez john locke que
l'individu est une personne rationnelle
responsable et
il faut en quelque sorte détacher de
l'individu tout un ensemble
d'institutions qui vont
l'interdire de faire des choses ou la
met à faire des choses qu'ils ne
souhaitaient pas à l'origine mais on a
aussi une autre tradition libérale moi
je considère comme étant une tradition
libérale qui est une tradition qui va
dire que l'individu
détacher de toutes les institutions
sociales n'est pas forcément libre
pourquoi parce qu'il va être une victime
d'autres aux pressions de l'oppression
privé par exemple communautaire et donc
le on va dire que une société de pure
individus dans lequel il n'y a plus
aucun état où plus aucun aucune
institution sociale c'est une société
dans lesquels en fait et bien les minus
oppresse les uns les autres donc ça
c'est la tradition de rousseau qui dit
le sel du contrat social de rousseau qui
dit que finalement pour émanciper les
individus et bien il faut avoir des
institutions sociales qui vont parfois
forcés alors c'est l'expression qui
l'utilisent forcer les individus à être
ni bas donc en fait l'idée de forcer les
individus être à être libre c'est bien
sûr une forme de contradiction dans le
temps l'expression mais ça veut dire que
pour rousseau les institutions sont pas
forcément incompatibles avec
l'émancipation individuelle en fait il
peut y avoir des institutions qui vont
libérer les individus et l'état n'est
pas forcément oppresseurs l'état peut
être aussi libérateur est en fait que
j'essaie de démontrer dans mon livre
c'est que le libéralisme la pensée
libérale là je parle ni d'armes
classiques est toujours un peu à cheval
sur lequel deux conceptions c'est à dire
d'une part elle aimerait bien que
l'individu
soit
détachée on va dire une toutes les
institutions sociales qui l'oppressent
religieux et autres mais d'autre part
elle est connue mais les héros considère
qu' il faut quand même que l'état
intervienne parfois lorsque c'est
nécessaire pour permettre l'émancipation
des individus un exemple très simple
c'est l'éducation
c'est-à-dire pour alan smith qui est
évidemment un libéral pur genzyme ilkin
aussi un libéral dans son livre le très
connu qui s'appelle de la liberté
l'éducation
doit être obligatoire doit être
organisée par l'état alors là il ya une
différence peu smith et mils smith 10
pour 2 il faut que dans toutes les tous
les villages tout est comme une lignée
des profs payés par l'état il dira non
il faut pas que l'état intervienne trop
directement mais il faut craindre ils se
permettent ils donnent de l'argent aux
familles pour qu'elles aillent éduquer
leurs enfants et puis tous les deux sont
d'accord pour obliger les familles à
éduquer leurs enfants
et donc il y à bien dans l'instruction
obligatoire
l'importance des institutions dans
l'émancipation des individus alors je
sais que je suis parti un peu loin mais
c'est pour vous faire comprendre que le
libéralisme classique c'est une forme de
réflexion qui vise à émanciper les
individus et dans cette réflexion le
rapport à l'état il est un peu en vue
parfois on dit il faut moins d'état pour
les individus sont plus libres du
darfour dit qu'il faut aussi de l'état
pour permettre
d'éviter les oppressions privé pour
permettre à chacun d'avoir une éducation
qui lui permettent d'être véritablement
émancipé
et j'ai en fait ce libéralisme il va
très rapidement au cours du 19ème siècle
se transformer en une forme on pourrait
dire d'ultra libéralisme c'est à dire
que toute la question émancipation des
amis du vin peut passer en arrière plan
et on va développer tout l'affluence de
ricardo par exemple un libéralisme de
laisser sert un libéralisme dans
lesquels on va considérer que l'état ne
doit surtout pas s'intéresser à
l'économie ne faut pas intervenir dans
l'économie et et se laisser servent à
organiser l'ensemble de la société
autour de marché qui doivent exister
sans être perturbés par enfin par l'état
donc ce libéralisme qu'on appelle le
libéralisme aussi bonne chez steria
puisqu'il vient dé
les industriels de manchester qui
s'appuyant sur ricardo pourront prendre
le tournant du libéralisme à au royaume
uni en 1846 avec
la fin du protectionnisme et ça va être
un libéralisme très dur et ce
libéralisme de laisser faire eh bien il
va rentrer en crise à la fin du 19ème
siècle au début du 20e siècle et cette
crise avec multiforme elle va d'abord
être une crise de l'état noir c'est à
dire que l'idée du libéralisme c'est
qu'il faut pas non plus de
l'ultralibéralisme il faut surtout pas
que l'état intervienne dans la monnaie
donc on a l'état noir sauf que en fait
en raison des déficits commerciaux
de sapins payer d'excédents commerciaux
pays en fait situé à certains pays qui
se retrouveront dépourvu d'or et qui du
groupe en plus adossé leurs monnaies sur
loire et puis il ya des désordres
sociaux qui apparaissent
siècle 20e siècle et puis il ya aussi la
concentration d'entreprises
industrielles qui vont devenir des
quasiment monopole
et qui va détruire la concurrence or le
l'idée du libéralisme de manchester sait
quand même que les marchés doivent être
régulées par la conférence s'il n'ya
plus de concurrence ya plus de
régulation et donc les marchés peuvent
oppressé à nouveau les prises d'antenne
au polar pas vous passer les dix
entreprises et donc c'est là qu'on va
commencer à mettre en place des
législations anti monopole antitrust en
1890 aux états unis et c'est là aussi
que en allemagne par exemple qu'on va
être représentée avec hart elle donc les
associations de producteurs industriels
qui vont en quelque sorte déstabiliser
l'économie et et bien sûr la crise qui
va chambouler complètement les
augmentations c'est la crise avait 30
qui émanent traque boursiers et dans
lesquels la réponse première des robes
raisons politiques au départ c'est à
dire bah il faut laisser faire il faut
pas que les quatre intervienne trop et
on voit bien que ça marche pas donc on
va avoir des états très
interventionniste ils vont chercher à
sortir de la crise évidemment c'est new
deal de roosevelt
et puis on va voir l'apparition d'un
adolf hitler en 1933 équipe en fait on
va voir le système politique se
désorganiser complètement sous l'effet
de la crise tout l'été les contestations
des alors on a d'une part les
communistes qui peu près par les
fascistes et les nazis et tous ses
pouvoirs politiques vont se renforcer à
l'occasion de la crise des années 30 et
donc pourquoi je vous dis ça parce que
d'un oeil au cours des années 30 les
libéraux sont sur la défensive et ils
essayent de de repenser le libéralisme
de refonder le libéralisme pour se dire
en fait le problème c'est que le
laisser-faire
souvent n'a pas permis de corriger les
problèmes du des marchés il n'a pas
permis de d'auto réguler la société à
partir des marchés et donc c'est ces
intellectuels à 21,30 conçoivent un
néolibéralisme donc en fait ce
néolibéralisme
il veut réactiver renouvelle libéralisme
mais en s'opposant c'est ça qu'il faut
comprendre et s'oppose au libéralisme
duvet s'étaient réunis il ne faut pas
laisser faire il faut construire un
ordre dans lesquelles
l'état va construire en fait
l'intervention pays doit construire un
lot dans lesquelles les marchés vont
voir s'épanouir et la concurrence sera
sauvegardée et en fait c'est cette re
nouvelle pensée du rôle de l'état c'est
à dire en fait faire de l'état
de l'intervention de l'état en fait
faire intervenir l'état pour réguler les
marchés pour faire en sorte que les
marchés puissent s'épanouir en fait on
va chercher on va considérer c'est ça
l'idée principale sur laquelle vont
s'appuyer les néolibéraux pas considérer
que le marché n'est pas quelque chose de
naturel quelque chose qui existe
naturellement c'est quelque chose qui
est construit par les institutions
sociales et donc ils vont penser le rôle
de l'état comme un rôle de construction
de ces institutions pour permettre au
marché d'exister en fait ce qui va être
l'une des choses qui vont chercher à
faire c'est notamment de réglementer la
concurrence parce que si l'état
intervient pas la concurrence peut
disparaître donc il faut des lois anti
anti monopole qui prestent ou contre les
cartels contre les ententes
il faut aussi et ça ils en ont
conscience à l'époque l'état
intervienne dans pour permettre pour
éviter les injustices sociales les plus
flagrantes donc ils conçoivent aussi le
principe de l'ordre social et quand on
lit les textes c'est l'une héros ils
disent tous par exemple il faut un
salaire minimum pour éviter que les gens
crèvent de faim parce que sinon dhj ce
vote trop criantes et la société va se
révolter donc ils pensent la question de
de
l'ordre social le fait qu'
il faut un minimum de revenus pour pour
chacun pour que chacun puisse intervenir
sur le marché
ils vont aussi penser autrement la
monnaie c'est à dire que la monnaie ils
vont ils vont s'apercevoir quand ils
vont à prendre acte vital et or ne
fonctionne plus donc il va falloir que
la mollesse géré par l'état et ça ça
veut dire que l'état doit prendre
or gagner très des institutions
monétaires qui vise à stabiliser les
prix à partir d'une monnaie qui soit
plus rattachés à l'état neuf ans donc
c'est dans les trente qu'on abandonne
l'idée de l'état noir mais on a donc il
faut bien que la monnaie est une manne
de quelque chose donc ça devient une
récente lp de l'état d'en gagner la
monnaie mais sans
sans altérer le fonctionnement des
marchés c'est-à-dire avec molex a pas
inflationniste et là on va voir tout un
ensemble d'institutions comme les
banques centrales indépendantes
le rôle premier accordé à la stabilité
des prix pas par ces banques centrales
donc tout ça ça apparaît dans le chai
dans la pensée libérale néo libérale
pardon à cette époque plus des dernières
choses auxquelles y pense ce dernier
pilier du néolibéralisme c'est le libre
échange et libre échange est fondamental
pour les néolibéraux comme pour les
libéraux d'ailleurs et sauf que le libre
échange et ça aussi c'est pas quelque
chose qui arrive de manière spontanée ça
ça se produit par des accords
commerciaux par les traités de libre
échange est donc là aussi il y à l'idée
que le libre-échange va pas arriver
spontanément et propres états
interviennent activement pour permettre
le libre échange donc en fait les quatre
piliers du néolibéralisme c'est une
nouvelle réflexion qui s'opposent au
dessert qui dit que l'état doit
intervenir pour garantir le libre
échange et garantir la stabilité
monétaire hilarante rire l'ordre social
et garantir la concurrence et c'est à
partir de ces quatre piliers quand on
croit que l'état a un rôle à jouer dans
ses calculs et selon moi on est un
néolibéral cd connaît un libéral
qui pensent que l'état a un rôle à jouer
dans deux dans le maintien de l'ordre
social
là pour répondre à la dernière question
dans cette tradition de libéral en fait
il ya plein de doctrine différentes et
il n'y a pas un néolibéralisme ya
plusieurs formes de nos libéralisme près
de toulon sera pas d'accord sur jusqu'où
on intervient par exemple vous préserver
la concurrence
quel est le bon mécanisme pour pour la
monnaie
quand on parle d'ordre social qu'est ce
que ça veut dire est ce que ça veut dire
que par exemple on va juste donné aux
aux jeunes un salaire à un revenu
minimal 1 7 crdi hayek par exemple ou
alors on va chercher à construire une
économie de partenariat avec les
syndicats voilà tout ça c'est pas le
même type d'intervention est donc l'ordo
libéralisme c'est une des écoles du
néolibéralisme c'est une école qui vient
d'allemagne
qui dont l'acte fondateur se fait en
1936 pendant le régime hitlérien c'est
celle des opposants farouches à hitler
mais il dispose d'une certaine autonomie
et
et ils vont essayer de penser là aussi
nouvelle forme de libéralisme mais un
libéralisme qui soient ancrés sur la
notion d'ordre avec l'association de
juristes et économistes dans lesquelles
l'une des choses qui pour mettre en
avant mais dans nos libéraux c'est
l'absolue importance de maintenir un
système de concurrence de maintenir un
ordre social
de permettre d'éviter l'oppression des
grandes entreprises sur les petites
entreprises de permettre l'accès au
marché à toutes les entreprises
d'organiser une stabilité monétaire et
donc en fait c'est tantôt libéralisme et
va se construire dans l'allemagne
d'après guerre
et il va incarner on va dire la nouvelle
allemagne de la seconde guerre mondiale
puis on a le libéralisme autrichien de
hayek donc c'est un là aussi c'est une
forme de néo libéralisme mais un
néolibéralisme beaucoup plus beaucoup
plus libérale si je puis dire
alors bon hayek dit également qu'il faut
les institutions sociales pour préserver
les marchés il est très ancrée sur la
question de droit
dit la conscience qu' il n'y existe des
institutions avec le marché sont pas des
choses naturelles donc on se sent si
l'union libérale mais par exemple lui va
être adepte à venir un peu sur le tard
mais partisan de ce qu'on appelle des
fruits banquiers c'est à dire de la
concurrence des monnaies les monnaies
doivent être privés pour courrier
d'autres néo libéraux sont parfaitement
d'accord si on à l'école de chicago
duncan freeman donc aux états unis
qui est elle aussi une école plutôt
libérale mais quand on lit milton
friedman on voit bien que nous y pense
que l'état doit jouer un rôle il le dit
lui-même il n'est pas un anarchiste ne
croit pas à la spontanéité des marchés
ils pensent qu'
il y avait notamment sur la question
monétaire il pense que la banque
centrale doit être régi par un ensemble
de règles
avec une augmentation de la masse
monétaire qui correspondent à
ce qu'on fonctionnel à l'augmentation du
pib et ce qui est ce que dit friedman
s'il faut surtout pas
très trop de monnaie donc il est ce
qu'on appelle monétariste si on va avoir
de l'inflation
voilà donc évidemment après il ya plein
plein de nuances et j'ai parenté en
détail mais le néolibéralisme pour
résumer c'est une doctrine qui qui met
en fait l'état au service du marché
parce que elles pensent les néo libéraux
pensent que le marché tout seul sans
l'aide de l'état eh bien il va tendance
il va avoir tendance à se dérégler et
donc à produire du chaos
voilà donc le l'ultralibéralisme pour
répondre bah c'est le libéralisme de
schiste est rien c'est l'idée qui
pensent que
l'économie doit fonctionner sans état le
libéralisme classique parfaite c'est une
philosophie qui vise à émanciper les
individus et qui dit pas des choses très
concrètes sur ce qu'il doit de faire
l'économie et le néolibéralisme c'est
vraiment une nouvelle doctrine qui met
l'état au service du marché et qui tend
à organiser le marché au pas par l'état
par l'intervention publique
vous avez parlé dans de dj dans salaire
minimum s'est ensuivi qui va être
bientôt d'actualité puisque nous sommes
à quelques mois de l'élection
présidentielle
et suite à la crise sanitaire ducobu de
19 l'idée d'instaurer un revenu
universel risque de refaire surface voir
dans le cadre de l'union européenne en
revenu universel européen certains
voient cette mesure que mon filet de
sécurité ou en planche et subsistance
pour que les travailleurs ne se révolte
pas leurs conditions qu'est ce que vous
en pensez alors attention il faut
distinguer salaire minimum est revenu
minimum c'est pas pareil
parce que voyez la différence le revenu
il est indépendant de toute intimité le
peu de travail alors le salaire c'est
celle liée à un travail une contrepartie
d'un travail les néo libéraux ne sont
pas pour un salaire minimum
traditionnellement ils sont pour un
revenu minimum pas tout à fait la même
chose à dire en fait pris une manne il
était par exemple ou un impôt négatif il
dit alors voilà on a un gros con
portionné pour éviter de le chambouler
les marchés et quand on est en dessous
d'un certain seuil et bien l'état va
financer les revenus en plus et c'est
différent du salaire minimum un minimum
il s'inscrit dans le cadre d'un rapport
de force employée employés alors que le
revenu c'est juste une allocation qui
est détaché de tout qui peut être
détachés de toute activité alors pour
revenir à la question du revenu minimum
bien justement le revenu minimum
contrairement au salaire minimum c'est
vraiment typiquement une idées
néo-libérales à c'est à dire que mana y
ont pensé que pour que le marché puisse
exister et puis ce pourrait qu'il soit
accepté par l'ensemble des gens eh bien
il faut donner aux gens de la capacité à
consommer et cette capacité à consommer
alors il a il pense pas qu'il faut que
ça soit un revenu très élevé pour eux
c'est parce que les couleurs du rsa
quelque chose de commande minimale mais
qui permet à tous et toutes les
personnes qui le touche de pouvoir
exister en quelque sorte de pouvoir agir
en tant que consommateur pour légitimer
le marché
alors je je
je ne sais pas ce que vous voulez me
faire dire par rapport à ça mais
là
l'idée de d'instaurer un revenu minimal
pour permettre aux gens de
d'acheter des choses était très mignonne
un consommateur pour moi ça c'est
typiquement une idée qui légitime le
marché
c'est pas du tout une idée qui va qui va
aller contre le marché ce qui va contre
le marché typiquement c'est les prix
réglementés
voilà dans le lit des néo libéral il
faut que les prix soient le produit de
l'offre et la demande or et c'est pour
cette raison qu'ils sont contre salaire
minimum parce qu'un salaire minimum
c'est un règlement d'un prix par contre
l'idée d'accorder à tous un minimum pour
survivre survivre ça c'est ça va
complètement dans leur dans leur logique
justement comment vous expliquer que
finalement cette proposition de là je
reviens vraiment de revenus
revenu universel soit prônée par des
partis de gauche qui par essence la
gauche ne voudrais pas être néolibérale
comment expliquer finalement que ce soit
eux qui soit porteur de cette mesure je
pense notamment à benoît hamon dans le
cas français
si vous avez une explication
alors oui oui mais alors l'explication
elle est un peu dur mais c'est ce que
j'essaie d'expliquer aussi dans mon
livre alors jamais dire aujourd'hui que
je ne parle pas de cela dans ce livre
alors j'ai travaillé sur l'animal dans
d'autres ouvrages mais papa d'antonella
techniquement mais ce que je dis dans
mon livre c'est que l'imaginaire
néolibérale n'est pas un imaginaire de
droite spécialement c'est un imaginaire
qui a conquis l'ensemble des esprits de
tout le monde dira que tout le monde
pense spontanément que le marché c'est
un système efficace pour allouer les
ressources y compris à gauche d'ailleurs
le néolibéralisme actuelle il a été en
grande partie portées par la gauche que
jacques delors et l'a traînée de marchi
munich lorsqu'il était président de la
commission européenne
l'ex-socialiste ont mis en oeuvre la
dérégulation des marchés des capitaux
des marchés financiers et s'ils l'ont
fait c'est parce qu'ils pensent que la
libéralisation des marchés produits de
l'efficacité ils en sont persuadés par
la pensée économique qui a commencé à
dire ça en train d'inventer comiques
comme tendance à le dire l'économiste et
les lois de l'offre et la demande c'est
là le
l'autorégulation des marchés et là où
les goûts les gens de gauche
interviennent ce qu'ils disent bas une
fois qu'on à l'efficacité parce qu on a
libéralisé les marchés parce qu'on a
entendu les allocations efficace alors
ensuite on peut compenser les injustices
avec des allocations est en fait la
gauche elle a complètement intégré deux
idées la première idée donc idées néo
libérales en fait qui est les marchés
sont efficaces les marchés doivent
décider des prix s'est pas à l'état
d'intervenir directement c'est à la
société privée s'ils sont tous les
privés à la sotech civile aux acteurs du
marché d'interagir spontanément entre
cependant deuxième idée de la gauche
il y à des injustices à l'issue du
marché il ya des inégalités qui
apparaissent et donc on compense égalité
avec les allocations et donc c'est
typiquement en fait quand on pousse
cette logique à bout eh bien on fait de
l'état n'ont pas un agent qui va
intervenir directement dans l'activité
économique non pas un état producteur
d'un état aux distributeurs qu'ils
valent et en fait c'est la critique que
je donne aussi à thomas piketty pascal
thomas piketty il me dit lui d'autres 1
il nous dit
il faut redistribuer les richesses il
faut par la fiscalité prélevées aux
riches pour rendre aux pauvres mais
aucun moment thomas piketty m'vila il
faut que l'état intervienne dans
l'activité économique que l'état de
nationaliser l'entreprise que l'état
produisent des richesses lui même
puisqu'ils ont complètement intégré
l'idée que se tient au coeur des cas
cités de l'activité mixer le marché est
en fait c'est un peu le souci c'est donc
en fait quand on couche l'idée des eaux
libéral on peut tout à fait arrivée sur
des des idées de gauche
vous pariez de rendre les allocations
sociales efficaces est-ce que vous
pouvez préciser votre propos là dessus
est ce que vous considérez que les à
l'iccat les allocations qu'on distribue
en nombre aujourd'hui en france sont
efficaces ou non
alors et l'efficacité ça dépend de
l'objectif c'est toujours une relation
entre des buts et les moyens c'est à
dire que si vous avez un certain but est
que vous mettez tel ou tel moyen si les
moyens correspondent à l'objectif que
vous ayez donné alors qu'il est efficace
si ça correspond pas vous êtes
inefficaces alors les allocations pour
moi ça fait partie des composantes
importantes et néolibéralisme puisque ce
qui est
encore une fois c'est au coeur du
néolibéralisme faire fonctionner les
marchés et on l'a vu dans la clé du co
lead
les gens disent qu'avec la crise due
qu'aux villes lorsqu'on a commencé à
dépenser puis on continue a dépensé à
fonds perdus pour aider les entreprises
les gens ont dit ben voilà on est sortis
néolibéralisme où on a retrouvé l'état
keynésien est en fait pas du tout ce que
le gouvernement en france et dans
d'autres pays d'ailleurs fait c'est
qu'ils ont voulu maintenir le système et
pour maintenir le système comme ils ont
comme commis de ferme et les entreprises
il voulait surtout pas qu'elle fasse
faillite et que tout le système
productif s'effondre donc ils ont
subventionné les entreprises qu'il
permet de manière à préserver leur
survie et donc de ce point de vue les
subventions accordées aux entreprises
pendant la crise ducobu ton totalement
et efficace puisque quand dd que dès
qu'on a réouvert les commerces et bien
retrouvé une activité économique très
forte et on s'est aperçu qu'il y avait
très peu de faillite est né là où c'est
intéressant c'est que ça veut dire que
là encore on met l'état au service du
marché c'est-à-dire que
quand on réfléchit sur la manière dont
on a répondu à la crise par exemple
c'est l'état s'est mis à subventionner
massivement les entreprises qui
fabriquent des vaccins donc tous les
états du monde ils ont commencé à donner
beaucoup d'argent à tout tout tout le
biomédical le secteur du no médical mais
à aucun moment l'état a dit ben on va
fabriquer nos propres vaccins en
nationalisant les androïdes
pharmaceutique donc il a refusé
d'intervenir directement il n'est
intervenu que par le biais des
subventions et pareil pour les ménages
l'autre pilier de la politique du covin
c'était de
financer les
et les personnes qui étaient au chômage
parce qu'il n'avait plus d'activité donc
on a fait le chômage partiel en france
d'échecs et d'envoyer des chèques aux
gens pourquoi pas ce que pareil s'il ya
plus de consommation n'y a plus de
production et donc il faut sauver le
marché faut sauver le marché du côté de
l'offre pour sauver le marché du côté de
la demande mais aucun moment et c'est
parce qu'en vrai en france lê thanh a
embauché des gens moi je fais partie des
écrits des tribunes dans la presse en
juin juin juillet 2020 pour tirer là
larmes parce que tous les étudiants qui
sortait de m2 à ce moment là eh bien ils
n'avaient pas dans mon boulot et il n'y
avait même pas de stage et je disais
mais enfin c'est pas mal sinon on a des
problèmes dans les écoles on a des
problèmes dans les hôpitaux
on a des étudiants qui terminent leur
formation et qui sont prêts à aider et y
compris vont comprend bien qu'ils vont
pas être médecin s'ils ont fait des des
master d'économie mais ils peuvent aider
quand même à gérer les hôpitaux et
peuvent quand même allé donner des cours
de soutien scolaire à des à des élèves
en ont besoin est mais l'état a refusé
l'état n'a pas créé un seul poste pour
répondre et même des postes en cdd pour
répondre à la crise et au vide laissé
les étudiants des merveilles et la
proposition dabo qui a reçu et se trouve
à l'est sinon c'est à dire d'en faire un
rsa jeunes comme si le fait de 600 euros
par mois allez des jeunes diplômés ça
allait les aider à s'insérer et à
construire leur vie en fait il aurait
fallu faire des emplois jeunes
quitte à ce soir encore une fois des
emplois à durée déterminée pour le temps
de crise et ça on refuse d'envoyer à
chaque fois on préfère donner les
allocations aux gens pour leur permettre
de continuer de consommer donc pour
soutenir le marché plutôt que de
chercher à les embaucher pour faire des
choses on préfère donner des subventions
à l'industrie pharmaceutique pour
qu'elles produisent des médicaments et
des vaccins plutôt que de nationaliser
l'industrie comme assedic pour soi-même
produire des vaccins de manière efficace
et de manière coordonnée aussi parce
qu'à une époque on avait 60 façon de
projet de vaccin dans le monde bon
est-ce qu'on avait besoin de temps le
projet de vaccin
voilà donc c'est intéressant de voir
comment l'état répond à une crise comme
celle d'hugo vide dans un régime
néolibéral
il répond pas en intervenant en
embauchant en nationalisant il répond en
distribuant de l'argent voilà merci ce
du couffin durant le mouvement des
gelées jaune voire qui essayent de
revenir les samedis en se mêlant aux
protestations contre contre le past and
i ter avec l'augmentation de l'essence
qui a dépassé des niveaux de l'époque
florissante des mouvements des yeux les
jeunes en tant qu'économiste et en tant
qu'économiste qui analyse aussi les
mouvements populistes quels sont pour
vous les les politique économique à
mettre en place
pour soutenir l'économie face aux coûts
vide mais aussi à mettre en place en
france pour répondre aux revendications
des gilets jaunes surtout face à un plan
de relance qui a été décidé dans un sou
l'échelle européenne et non nationale un
plan qui a été
insuffisant quand on compare par exemple
avec les états unis que qu'est-ce que la
france devrait faire surtout que les
prochaines années comme vous parler d
eux des étudiants qui peinait à trouver
un stage un emploi qu'est ce que la
france devrait faire qu'est ce qu'un
état européen
alors là il ya beaucoup de questions
derrière votre question
la première ce dg avait caractérisé ce
que c'est que populisme et notamment le
mouvement des jeunes au départ le moment
mais gilet jaune c'est un mouvement pour
contester les taxes sur le gasoil
et qui se comprend par le fait que
l'essence augmentait beaucoup avec les
prix du pétrole qui augmentent et elles
et à rajouter à cette augmentation en
augmentant les taxes au nom de
l'écologie sauf que pour ces personnes
là où beaucoup de gens
n'y a pas de choix c'est à dire que la
voiture est un impératif pour les au
travail parce qu'ils habitent à 20
kilomètres du centre-ville et qu' ils
n'ont pas le choix il n'y a pas de
transports en commun et donc là aussi on
a une gestion de comment dire de
l'écologie qui globalement est une
gestion néolibérale c'est à dire qu'elle
joue sur les prix elle va augmenter les
prix et donc changer les incite les
incitations sans agir directement par
exemple en
construisant des transports collectifs
pour permettre aux gens de se déplacer
parce que finalement si on court on
construit un campement collectif on
remet des trains voilà là où il y en a
plus on remet transports collectifs
alors à ce moment là on devient des dits
modérés voilà des coûts maintenant vous
avez une solution interactive donc ne
prenez pas la voiture et je vais
renchérir le coût du le coût du gasoil
est en fait les l'état néolibéral il ne
fait jamais ça veut dire qu'ils ne
donnent pas les gens aux gens les moyens
de changer leur comportement ils créent
juste des incitations pour reprendre une
analogie par rapport aux passes vagues
n'ont pas accès nahla qui a été mis en
place je trouve ça incroyable
et ça lui se veut totalement l'état
néolibéral ça aussi qu'est-ce que macro
nous dit il dit vous êtes libre de vous
vacciner ou pas le vacciner mais je vais
chercher à vous inciter à vous vacciner
en interdisant tout un ensemble accès à
des services pour ceux qui sont pas
vaccinés donc ces principes du patineur
mais à aucun moment l'état n'a dit eh
bien écoutez voilà je vais convoquer les
gens pour avoir une dose de vaccin et à
aucun moment la sécurité sociale nous a
envoyé un courrier pour dire voilà vous
avez un credo de vaccination tel jour
telle heure présentez-vous et si vous
n'êtes vous ne venez pas eh bien vous
aurez éventuellement une amende si on
prend un vaccin obligatoire une même
sans rendre le vaccin obligatoire juste
qu'est ce que fait que ce que fait
l'état il demande aux gens d'aller eux
mêmes chercher un créneau avec un
opérateur privé qui n' octo libre pour
se faire vacciner et il va créer des
incitations pour obliger les gens à sa
maxi départ pour inciter les gens à
faire patiner sans les obliger vraiment
à le faire
c'est une logique complètement aberrante
les gens qui n'ont pas l'habitude
d'internet ou qui parfois sont un peu
démuni pour trouver la manière de ses
racines et parfois il manque un peu de
confiance
puisqu'on passe par des institutions
privées les pharmacies sont aussi les
institutions privées lock tony blair
c'est une nation privée et la sécurité
sociale à aucun moment ne nous aide à
trouver un créneau ça fait quand même un
problème alors je reviens sur le
populisme du populisme il vient du fait
que tout un ensemble de populations n'a
plus confiance dans les institutions et
à mon avis si des gens n'ont plus
confiance dans les institutions c'est
parce que ils ont l'impression que les
institutions jouent contre leur intérêt
que la démocratie est perverti que
l'état est impuissant et qu'il accepte
totalement son impuissance ou qu'il est
corrompu par les intérêts privés et est
en fait ce que j'essaie de démontrer
dans mon livre c'est que cette
impression elle n'est pas fausse c'est
un pressoir et s'appuie sur des faits
qui sont tout à fait avéré qui est que
l'état en se mettant au service du
marché par le principe néolibérale et
bien
construit sa propre impuissance
c'est à dire que comme j'ai dit il il ne
produit plus lui-même il incite les
individus à se comporter deux thèmes de
le passant par les mécanismes de prix
et du coup ça donne l'impression que par
ils ne craignent rien lui-même et qu' il
ait des intérêts privés pour le cas des
légers les jaunes c'est assez
intéressant puisque en fait ce que ce
que macron la politique de mâcon qui
l'amenait mais qui était aussi celle de
hollande mais qui était aussi celle de
sarkozy accord c'est une politique ou
confrontées à une intensification de la
concurrence c'est à dire au fait que
chaque pays doit
chercher à être en concurrence avec
d'autres pays pour pour avoir du capital
pour avoir des investissements des
entreprises eh bien l'état français a
cherché à accorder aux investisseurs des
taux de profit supérieur est toute la
politique actuelle de la france c'est
d'augmenter le taux de profit de
l'entreprise pour que quand une
entreprise de choisir un site
d'investissement elle choisit la france
plutôt que l'espagne ou l'allemagne et
donc pour ça on a fait basculer la
fiscalité des entreprises vers les
ménages on est con abaisser la fiscalité
des entreprises donc c'est tout le
principe de
force et du prélèvement propriétaire
unique qui est l'impôt à 30 % sur tous
les revenus du capital c'est le principe
bien sûr de la suppression du sfc le
principe de la diminution du taux
d'impôt sur les sociétés c'est le
principe de la diminution à ce qu'on
voit que le prends le plan de relance
dès de lahti ciel des impôts de
production donc on baisse tous les
impôts qui touche les entreprises parce
que les entreprises elles peuvent
choisir veut mettre en concurrence la
france avec d'autres pays et du coup
forcément sombre avec un manque à gagner
si on a baissé tous les impôts des
entreprises dont il va pas qu'on trouve
d'autres recettes mais les autres
recettes quand on dit qu'on veut pas
augmenter les impôts eh bien ça va être
les taxes taxe sur le gasoil plaque sur
la cigarette taxes sur l'alcool
et tout un ensemble d'autres
prélèvements puis ça suffira pas donc
est ce qu'on va faire va baisser les
bras gelé les salaires et puis on va
chercher à diminuer nos fonctionnaires a
dit rembourser des choses par exemple
augmentent attire d'autres d'autres
trucs et puis on va faire la réforme des
retraites pour essayer de lier un peu
d'argent donc en fait toute cette
logique que les gens voir c'est à dire
que l'état semble être au service des
entreprises plutôt qu'à être au service
de ses électeurs eh bien ça s'appuie sur
des faits réels c'est à dire que dans le
cadre de sa stratégie
d'attractivité l'état baissent la
fiscalité des puissants des entreprises
augmentent de tête les préventes les
fiscaux sur les ménages et ça ça crée
une défiance qui est la base du
populisme et voyez comment eric zemmour
lui aussi alors on était là aucune idée
nouvelle 1 mais ils s'appuient sur cette
défiance pour dire voilà je vais
chercher à
retrouver la france parce que derrière
quand on a l'impression que macron c'est
un traître je suis parti aux populations
qui pensent qu'on a consacré traite à la
france un très tôt au peuple et donc ça
nourrit nos rancoeurs qui va se traduire
par un parent d vote extrémiste des
votes populiste
alors qu'est ce qu'il faudrait faire et
bien de mon point de vue nico que que
comment dire que l'état mette la
politique devant devant devant les
costumes c'est à dire qu'il vise que son
rôle c'est de répondre aux attentes de
ses électeurs et non pas de jouer le jeu
de l'attractivité est là le problème
c'est que jouer le jeu de l'attractivité
c'est le jeu de la concurrence c'est le
jeu qui existent de par les institutions
européennes actuelles de par la
mondialisation
et quand on a une liberté totale des
mouvements de capitaux et quand on a
du libre échange absolu au coeur là
aussi bine et au libéralisme et bien on
se retrouve démuni si on veut mener une
politique par exemple qui va favoriser
d'autres sociaux alors toutes les
entreprises de france en dire des godets
si le coût du travail augmente en contre
moi il fallait produire en allemagne ou
en belgique ou en
chine au vietnam
par exemple les les masques que l'état
achète va chercher à distribuer aux
enseignants des masques ou d'enseignants
et les deux bons ils seront tous
produits au vietnam marocain qui sera
connue en france pourquoi pas ce qu'il
va chercher le moins coûteux et pourquoi
il fait ça parce qu'en fait il n'y a pas
de politique commerciale a donc derrière
la question
de sentiments de disparition de la
france que peuvent avoir les électeurs
de zemmour il y a donc connu un
sentiment beaucoup plus fort plus
pertinents qu'ils aient le sentiment de
démantèlement de la puissance de l'état
parce que l'état ayant accepté le cadre
de la mondialisation se privent de la
capacité
d'acheter des masques fabriqués en
france par exemple ou de
réhabiliter son industrie en menant des
politiques industrielles 1 pourquoi ne
pas mener une politique haïtienne parce
que vous ça c'est interdit par les
traités européens qui disent concurrence
libre et non faussée si l'état
intervient il faut sa conférence il faut
ce marché s'établit
donc il faut penser
que l'économie doit être au service de
la population et pour cela il faut
réguler à nouveau intervenir à nouveau
dans le marché dans l'économie pour
permettre de faire en sorte que
l'économie soit observé la société et
non pas la société au service de
l'attractivité et la compétitivité
vous avez dû mentionner le fait que
la population avait le sentiment qu'on
taxer davantage les honnêtes
travailleurs que les grandes entreprises
ça a été en partie une cause du
mouvement des gilets jaunes
donc ce mouvement des îles et jaune et
donc les tentatives de récupérations
politiques ont renouvelé le débat sur
les différentes formes de populisme en
tant qu'économiste qui analyse les
mouvements populistes notamment dans
votre dernier ouvrage quels sont pour
vous les politiques économiques à mettre
en place en france pour répondre aux
revendications des gilets jaunes sans se
contenter de distribuer des chèques mais
c'est ça que je cliquais pour reprendre
le contrôle ceux qui on card populisme
c'est la défiance la défiance envers les
institutions ont le sentiment que le
président le gouvernement
l'ensemble des institutions y compris
les scientifiques les médecins les les
journalistes ne ne répond plus aux
attentes populaires et cette impression
elle n'est encore pas n'est pas fausse
elle est fondée elle est fondée sur la
manière dont l'état néolibéral hadji
c'est à dire que il cherche à attirer
des entreprises et donc il met en avant
au coeur de sa politique l'attractivité
de son territoire au détriment des
services public par exemple et pour pour
répondre à cela
pour répondre à ce sentiment de défiance
eh bien il faut retrouver un état qui
est capable de produire des choses mais
on a évidemment va se trouver face à un
problème qui est l'articulation
mondialisation union européenne états
voire région collectivités territoriales
et se pose une grande question qui est
qui est légitime pour intervenir est-ce
que c'est l'union européenne est ce que
c'est ma commune ma région où l'état est
un moment par rapport à ça j'ai une
réponse très simple qui est pas une
réponse générale qui est une réponse qui
qui qui en fait spécifique n'est pas
dire il faut regarder où se fait le
débat démocratique où a lieu
l'expression populaire
et ça peut être tout à fait à l'échelle
d'une région ça pourrait être pourquoi
pas à l'échelle d'un continent mais il
se trouve que quand on pense à la
question démocratique
quand on regarde un pays comme la france
pour moi il est à peu près clair que
l'expression démocratique le débat
démocratique se fait à l'échelle
nationale dire que les gens ils
connaissent mieux leur président köhler
président de conseil régional par
le mak rond est connue la part de la
population
le président de la commission la
président de la commission cela peut
même meilleur n'est pas connu de la part
des gens et donc ça veut dire que ils
s'identifient à une communauté nationale
et c'est cette reconnaissance nationale
qui parce qu'elle est démocratique et
légitime pour pour agir sur l'économie
et donc il faut remettre du pouvoir là
où il ya la démocratie en fait pour le
dire très simplement mais ça ça
permettra de répondre aux attentes des
gilets jaunes et de l'ensemble du
mouvement populiste mais ça ça demande
de
réinterpréter les les rapports qu'il
existe entre les différentes
institutions qui nous gouvernent c'est à
dire que si on pense que la démocratie
donc doit être au coeur de la société
alors il faut que l'espace de dialogue
discussions de débats démocratiques et
pour moi l'espace national soit là où se
prennent les décisions et nous de se
décider de
l'avenir de l'économie
et pour finir sur une dernière question
qui peut paraître n'a rien à voir mais
finalement si vous avez parlé de
défiance est je pense un terme qui est
rim qui est surveillance donc je pense à
l' ouvrage de la sociologue américaine
shoshana zubov qui a publié en 2010 neuf
ouvrages l'âge du capitalisme de
surveillance où elle explique que le
capitalisme de surveillance est un
projet global de modification du
comportement humain qui menace de
transformer la nature humaine au 21ème
siècle la même façon que le capitalisme
industriel a modifié le monde au 20e
siècle et du coup comment vous
voyez-vous ce nouveau capitalisme et
comment les outils du numérique
remet-il en cause ce néolibéralisme
alors le gg j'ai lu le livre de double
jeu intéressant et en même temps un peu
limité vers caen fait son idée alors
récente elle dit aujourd'hui les gars
femmes pour le dire vite les 30 sociétés
d'internet
font de l'argent par l'extraction de
données personnelles nos comportements
dans en tant qu'internaute et
tout ça à 10 c'est contraire à
l'autonomie des individus
ce que je reproche à sochaux chanaz
obock dans la palissade la manière de
présenter les choses c'est que elle voit
toujours là aussi l'individu seul isolé
autonome donc de ce point de vue là elle
est totalement libérale et les atteintes
à l'individu sont des attaquants
autonomie et voilà il ne pense pour moi
ce qui manque dans son libre c'est une
réflexion plus globale des rapports
sociaux et notamment des rapports entre
l'état l'espace démocratique et les
grandes entreprises les grandes firmes
multinationales et moi j'ai lu un autre
ouvrage que je trouve absolument
intéressant que j'ai
là mais je vais pas vous montrer tout de
suite mais c'est les bras de cédric
durand techno féodalisme une critique de
l'économie numérique est en fait ce que
dit ce récurrent
donc c'est publiant 2020 ce que dit
cédric durand c'est que le régime qui
est en train d'arriver aujourd'hui c'est
un régime qui va dépasser le capitalisme
qui est un régime de type féodal et
pourquoi c'est un régime de type féodal
parce que ces grandes sociétés en fait
elles luttent les unes contre les autres
en le nom des sauces des généralistes
vont fournir tout un ensemble de
services
et elles vont se comporter comme des
rentiers et non pas comme des
entrepreneurs et ce qui est intéressant
dans l'entrée du rance et qu' il va
beaucoup plus loin il n'analyse pas
juste les problèmes que ça pose sur
l'autonomie l'autonomie des individus
mais il passe interrogé sur le point de
la pause sur l'ensemble du système
économique en général et donc ce système
là pour moi c'est un vrai challenge
c'est à dire que
face à des entreprises qui deviennent
toute puissante parce que elle domine un
environnement numérique
les pouvoirs de régulation de l'état
devient extrêmement faible et même
j'ai envie de dire l'espace même du
marché disparaît ça c'est un truc que
suri durant même ne nie pas mais que je
dis dans un article qui est bientôt
publié
c'est à dire que quand on a une taupe
c'est comme bear par exemple urbr ou met
en relation ou renminbi il met en
relation des offreurs et demandeurs à
dire que elles font ce que paie un
marché on a des conducteurs de
chauffeurs hubert ou et puis on a des
utilisateurs de transport est en fait
sur un marché n'y aurait normalement une
négociation libre entre le producteur et
le consommateur
or le fonctionnement de ces plateformes
c'est qu'elle remplace le marché c'est
que en fait ce sont elles qui ont gagné
la transaction ce sont elles qui
décident des prix ce sont elles qui
sécurise le fonctionnement de cette
activité est en fait le
la dynamique
l'extension de ces de sega femmes de ces
grandes entreprises d'internet va en
fait supprimer le marché puisqu'il n'y a
plus à voir un espace public dans
lesquelles les offreurs de vendeurs se
retrouver négocier entre eux maintenant
on a un espace privé organisé par des
algorithmes dans lesquelles une
entreprise va trouver mettre en relation
l'offre halal demandeur à un prix
qu'elle va elle même décidé dans des
modalités qu'elle va elle aussi décidé
et donc ça c'est disparition du marché
en tant que système d'organisation de
l'offre et la demande et du coup moi ce
que j'en déduis c'est que le
néolibéralisme en fait c'est une
idéologie qui ne peut plus penser cela
parce que j'ai dit le néolibéralisme y
pense le marché pense comme le rôle de
l'organisation sociale et économique
doit être passé par le marché or le ces
entreprises et grandes entreprises
internet et bien elle remplace le marché
et ce sont des pouvoirs économiques et
donc la la la la vision néolibérale en
fait elle n'a plus aucun sens si on a
plus de marché on peut plus penser comme
un néo libérale et donc bah là il faut
entièrement repensé le management de
l'organisation sociale qui est le
produit
produit par ses soucis qu'est ce qu'on
va pouvoir s'arrêter par là on pourra
encore parler des heures on avait encore
plein d'autres questions
malheureusement on va publier des autres
vue de plusieurs heures donc vous
remercie sincèrement pour le temps que
vous allez prix je recommande à ceux qui
nous écoutent de lire vos ouvrages qu'on
a qu'on a mentionné tout au long de
l'entrevue est donc de nous suivre sur
scopeo et de s'abonner bien sûr et la
chaîne youtube pour pouvoir suivre les
entrevues qui vont arriver très bientôt
et bien merci à vous croire à cette
occasion et puis et puis bah écoutez moi
une bonne suite un pour votre chaîne